in this video today we will be
discussing in detail about the hollow
earth scenes from the trailer and the tv
spots
that was recently shown to us if you
haven't seen them then i suggest you
watch the trailer
and then the recent teaser videos that
we have also posted in our channel
and if you already have then let us get
down to it
godzilla vs com will feature a couple of
storylines that will eventually connect
in the later part of the movie and this
will end in a climactic battle between
the two monsters
and also maybe another mecca that they
would have to team up against
but anyway one of the storylines would
be about kong travelling down to the
hollow earth
to find his origins and therefore
setting up the stage
for the final meeting with the big g in
the first trailer we saw glimpses of the
hollow earth
firstly when kong was seen jumping and
landing like a superhero near a
waterfall
in the background we could see green
hills that were seemingly upside down
and also clouds that cling onto those
inverted landscapes
this is all possible because of the
hollow earth it's in fact
like the place where corn was traveling
to is at the center of the earth
and the question arises as to how is
this possible you may ask
aren't they supposed to float like in
space um
not really well gravity is a strange
creature every particle atom or
substance
attracts every other substance and vice
versa
the fact that we are standing on the
surface of the planet is because most of
the mars
of the earth is below us so it attracts
us
down when you're at the center of the
earth and it is hollow
the mass of the earth is everywhere else
except there
so the attraction is towards the surface
of the planet from there
and since it is spherical around the
hollow earth it will also have
curvatures and the mountains and
landscape would stick to it being
attracted upside down
okay done with that i hope you
understand what i'm saying
we already discussed that kong would
find out about his ancestry and that
there was a huge war
between the species of kong and godzilla
in the ancient bars
and this led to the eviction of both
these titan species to the surface of
the planet
and on the cover of godzilla vs kong art
book which
is going to be released in march we see
kong with an
axe against godzilla but surprisingly
with two group of humans
that are on either side of the conflict
team kong vs team godzilla
just like the comments section so yeah
kong finds a handprint of an earlier ape
and then he retrieves the battle axe aka
this titan storm breaker
but not before battling a couple of
warbats on nuzuki and also a swarm of
hellbaths
in the chamber of the axe so now we come
to the scene of the tv spot
showing the extent of the hollow earth
and where kong and his companions are
traveling to
but before that maya asked if the monkey
is able to
survive the journey to the center of the
earth and also that they have to take
jia along with them
so that kong would follow them there com
has a very special connection with jia
and this isn't new as
the earlier versions of kong from all
his previous movies
show him being in a deep connection with
a human female and so
in the monster verse it is jia the
little girl
they then travel through a newly found
passage that is
kind of like a vortex like the ones that
godzilla uses to make its way around the
world
around the ocean in record time then we
see the hollow earth in all its glory
as it stretches from hundreds or even
thousands of miles in either direction
and then there are huge mountain ranges
all over the place
up down sides everywhere and the biggest
ones converge on a point where
a huge energy cloud with a strong burst
of lightning occurs
this is also maybe the source of light
and sort of an inner sun
that breeds life into the flora and
fauna over there
kong and the two atavs or the hollow
earth anti-gravity vehicles
then make their way over there as it
could be the place where he finds his
lineage
and a battle axe inside that cave in the
mountains
the most interesting part of this scene
is the bluish glowing rocks that appear
to form like streams of energy
around the hill leading to the mountains
they emanate
the same color as godzilla's dorsal
plates when pulsating with nuclear
energy
and also the same as the ground that
kong was standing on
when he was facing up against the
warbats on the first trailer
they could be the source of radiation
that spurts are tightened to grow as
big as they could and since there were
none of those on the surface that's why
life form over here are smaller in size
but that is just a theory it could very
well be energy sources that ancient
humans might have
tapped into it as well so that's that
all we have on the hollow earth and with
it we come to the end of this video
if you have your own theories then
please share it with everyone in the
comments section
anyway it's been a blast do like for
support
smash the subscribe button to be a part
of the mind cave family
and also slap slap slap that
notification bell to get regular updates
on monster content right here on mind
cue
take care fam